[Musique]
après love island nabila est de retour à
la présentation d'un tout nouveau format
sur amazon prime
[Musique]
time intitulé cosmique love si le
principe reste toujours le même trouver
l'amour cette fois ci les quatre
candidats célibataires vont devoir se
fie à l'astrologie la plateforme n'a pas
encore communiqué la date de diffusion
et l'émission s'annonce déjà lunaire
alors que smic love que réserve la
nouvelle émission de nabila sur amazon
[Musique]
alors vous y croyez oui non oui monde y
croit j'ai quelques infos de la
production donc le concept parfaite
c'est une émission de dating qui va
permettre aux gens de trouver l'amour en
fonction de leur signe astrologique le
tournage il aura lieu à malte cet été
c'est la troisième fois que la médaille
collabore avec amazon elle a fait le
bilan des la faire de commentaire sur l
île ont créé content de l'engagement
qu'elles génèrent parce qu'avec thomas
je crois qu'ils ont 10 millions
d'abonnés sur instagram et pour son
contrat on parlera contrat à sept
chiffres c'est un contrat énorme regret
de plus d'un million d'euros à ces sept
chiffres plus d'un million d'euros et
c'est apparemment mérité puisque nabila
général vrai engagement quelques
bêtises mais je crois que sur les
plateformes soit amazon netflix le on a
du mal à calculer une audience qu'en
fait si vous cliquez sur le programme et
même je regardais une millième 35 ans
c'est dire que vous l'avez mutation
après concrètement ils s'en foutent de
l'audience utilisions un système
d'abonnement donc les gens payent 20 30
euros par mois il ya tant d'abonnés et
husky ce qui l'intéresse c'est la
qualité des émissions et la satisfaction
des abonnés
collaboration ça veut dire qu amazon et
vous vous y croyez j'y crois parce que
en fait c'est tout simplement une façon
de renouveler cette émission de dating
alors un coup c'est blind est un coup
c'est on connaît pas qui on va se marier
sans connaître maintenance et ils ont
trouvé l'horoscope après ce sera
chose du 38 33 donc c'est une façon on
effondré de renouveler un peu de malines
mans le truc dans le monde et elle l
avait fait à tf1 nous il ya longtemps
selon le signe astral 1 vous rappelez il
ya que deux personnes qui ne me croit
pas c'est à l'heure pierre verdy croyez
pas est-ce que nabila pour vous c'est un
peu un phénomène qui en descente nom
sacré je la trouve admirable d'accord
qu'elle a réussi à se réinventer parce
qu'elle part quand même de loin de entre
guillemets des ruches de télé réalité et
au final elle a réussi à gérer sa
carrière au final faire des jeux
elle a utilisé ce fait tout le monde a
cru qu'elle était bête mais pas du tout
celle qui a le mieux géré sa carrière
mais maintenant cette émission là c'est
quand même un truc pour les filles je
pense que pas beaucoup de gars on le
regarde bien une truc de d'astrologie
tout ça ça ne m'intéresse pas mais les
filles y en a plein qui sont dans ce
délire donc je pense que ça les
intéresse je suis une protection
vraiment il ya des gens qui choisissent
leurs partenaires en fonction du cygne
honnêtement oui j'en
suis assez intelligent là sur m6 mari au
premier regard qui cartonne mais avec un
espèce de concept bancal on dit qu'à des
compatibilités des compatibilités
scientifique on comprend rien là le
signe astrologique ya plein de gens qui
disent dans la vie à toi tu es cancer
moi j'suis scorpions s'entend bien on
s'entend pas je trouve ça répond à une
vraie demande des gens et sa conception
on est d'accord guillaume que c'est un
artifice dans la vraie vie tu vas tomber
sur delphine je vais [ __ ] fois
amoureux d'elle elle te dis ah ben je
suis eu son nom comme ça je
voulais pas je pense qu'il ya déjà
suffisamment démission dans le genre de
dating mariée au premier regard sur
netflix donc leurs concurrents il ya
loveth brain qui cartonne
aux etats-unis une version brésilienne
ça cartonne là je pense que c'est
totalement artificielle justement de
baser sur moi je crois en l'astrologie
mais il faut faire vraiment le thème
astral complet etc ce fût ce le signe
solaire qui compte donc c'est vraiment
basé sur un gadget et je veux je n'y
crois pas mais on s'en fout
on s'en fou ce qu'on regarde c'est
nabila et qu'elle répond à la gestion
drôle amener les gens à venir pour
nabila oui on va venir prendre la bilan
bien sûr parce qu'on sait qu'elle est
intelligente et qu'elle a des saillies
comme ça elle a détaillé airbus comme
personne va se marier avec oui bah oui